just wanted to quickly mention this is
an article on the npr on an npr
affiliate website
and the title is men like me benefit
from safe abortion access
and uh
i forget who the author of this is
because i copy and pasted it here i wish
i wish i could tell you the name of the
guy who wrote this but maybe it doesn't
matter
um and going down a little bit the
article says men like me
have also long been the direct
beneficiaries of safe abortion access
giving women the choice not to carry
unwanted pregnancies often means we too
can delay parenthood until we are ready
since i've spent 10 of the past 11 years
as a student most of the women i've had
sex with were also students also
progressive and also not at point in
their lives when they were looking
already to have children i try to share
responsibility for birth control and if
a woman tells me she's on it i also
trust that if she still got pregnant
however though entirely her decision i
assume we would both want the same thing
in abortion in longer terms
relationships we've had explicit
discussions about this
it's the duty of both sexual partners to
be proactive about safe sex but in
reality too often this burden falls
disproportionately on women oh that's
nice so he's concerned about women too
admittedly i've often relied on my
female sexual partners to protect me
from unwanted pregnancy during my mba i
recall panicking in an uber to the train
station after hanging out with a medical
student i had met on tinder and we had
seen a few times she had a latex allergy
we didn't use our best judgment then i
got her text she had decided to take
plan b as an extra precaution i was
relieved
to my knowledge i've never gotten anyone
pregnant on an academic level i followed
the entrenched decades-long conservative
effort to undermine access to safe
abortions yet until this moment i viewed
accessible abortion as something my
partners and i could reasonably rely on
as a last resort uh and then he goes on
and on and on talking about how he
really benefits from this i actually
yeah this article provoked i guess some
mostly jeers and mockery which is what
it deserves a little bit of outrage as
well on the right but
i'm all about the jeers and mockery for
something like this i'm not outraged at
all in fact i i very much
appreciate this article and and i'm
happy that this guy
wrote it
um because what he's saying here is
exactly
correct this is a hundred percent true
that abortion benefits it doesn't just
benefit i think it primarily benefits
no i don't think it does primarily
benefit
weak effeminate um limp-wristed
pathetic loser-lazy
despicable shameful men like this
they are the beneficiaries of abortion
and so i'm very happy when any of them
can stand up and say yep that's me and i
and i love abortion so that other women
can look at this guy and say like this
this is this is what abortion is for
it's not for you it's for that guy
this guy who's managed to find multiple
sexual partners somehow which speaks to
the
collapse of standards
in our culture today which is which is a
problem in and of itself
but that's who abortion is for
certainly not for women
because that's the guy
who is going to benefit from it quote
unquote
and will suffer not at all
he pays no price
so he's got no skin in the game
um after the sexual act is complete
anyway
he suffers no he suffers now if he if he
had a conscious conscience
you know if he had a conscience if he
had any kind of moral sense at all
then he would suffer he would suffer
greatly
um from the moral guilt of what he's
done
but fortunately for him he is as c.s
lewis would describe him a man with no
chest he has no conscience
and uh and no dignity no shame
right
and
none of that no no sense of honor
and uh he sees other people especially
other women as just objects to be used
as glorified masturbatory aids and as as
essentially sex fleshy sex robots is how
he sees them
and so abortion is just all about
avoiding um
responsibility so he can continue being
irresponsible and using women without
ever having to pay any kind of price for
that whatsoever
now the women on the other hand
um
there's there's a very steep cost that
they pay physically
there's the physical toll of abortion
which is significant
there's the physical damage that
abortion can cause
such as potentially making so you can
never have kids again also significant
but then also
the guilt and the trauma
is much harder for women to escape
because they're the ones going through
this
you hear you might hear from the shout
your abortion crowd oh it was great it
was fantastic and i had an abortion then
we went we went afterwards to taco bell
it's just like a it was a day out you
know it's just like running errands
they talk about it like that but that's
that's it's not true that's a
rationalization
only men like this can
can can really choose to be that
flippant about it in real life
so yeah
he's the primary beneficiary that's what
abortion is all about it's all for him
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content